greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by CBD Lyon calm listen everybody's
trying to [ __ ] shove CBD down your
throat you don't even know what you're
putting down that with CBD Lyon calm you
know exactly what you get the best go to
CBD Lyon calm right now and check out
their third party lab results for
yourself they come in a vape they come
in cartridges or the shadow but if
you're not into smoking you can either
gummy one of the raspberry one
strawberry ones or orange ones that
listen CBD Lyon is the way to go trust
me
go to CBD line comm right now where to
pick the tincture the gummies the shanna
the vape anything you go press in church
on the way out and get 20% off
that's what uncle Joey's doing for you
to kick off this [ __ ] fall okay it's
a [ __ ] Labor Day weekend you're
still not on CBD you're still not taking
care yourself go to CBD line calm right
now press in church and get 20% of check
out the church is also brought to you by
my bookie listen [ __ ] that's it
tomorrow football season is upon us you
like winning money you're like betting
sports all right
I'll tell you what to put your money
down ready grab a pen my book e.com if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
MMA UFC whatever the [ __ ] you got my
bookies got it they got better
incentives and more lines than any other
sports book period and this year they're
running our super contests you ready a
hundred miles to enter you pick five
teams a week against the spread and you
rack up the points first place
guaranteed gets you $100,000 plus they
just revamped their site and it's
looking [ __ ] tremendous so go take a
look if you haven't already now do me a
favor this is how we're gonna start
football season all right you're gonna
double down on your deposit right now
we're gonna double your first deposit
right now double your first deposit
today right now use promo code Church
and get a hundred percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to it ow
and ours that means you put $1,000 in
when they put in Li a thousand what a
[ __ ] you gonna get that from that's how
uncle Joey takes care who's better than
you nobody so go to my bookie that AG
today that's my bookie
that AG do not forget to use the promo
code Church when creating your account
because then you can't claim your bonus
listen with my bookie dot AG you play
you win you get paid and check my
Instagram on Thursdays I'll be dropping
a video for my bookie every week uncle
Joey is my bookie follow me at mad
flavors world kick this [ __ ]
mealy so did you go to Brandeis high
school now I went to Baruch College
campus high school were you supposed to
go to Brandeis did you have an option go
to because that was not that but that
was the West Side school yeah that was
East Side okay you only eat so I grew up
on I like East like 97 and down the east
side like I was born in Mount Sinai
which is up on like what isn't that like
98 or something 90 100 or something like
that and like fifth and then we moved
over to 82nd Central Park West and then
fourth grade we moved downtown we moved
to these village so I spent like my
formative years on Astor Place and watch
that neighborhood just completely flip
over
that is crazy yeah how are you siblings
one little brother that's it that's it
well your parents - growing up my folks
had a dance studio my mom was a ballroom
dancer oh [ __ ] yeah and my dad like ran
the studio with my mom no [ __ ] yeah
so it's been in your blood
yeah like they were just super
supportive this cuz they they did it and
they kind of like my mom's from Scotland
born and raised in Scotland came here
when she was in her 20s and [ __ ] so her
whole idea in America is that you really
could do whatever like I would really I
would remember her like as a kid she
would tell me like vivid memories my mom
just gone you can do anything you want
she goes you know if you if you reach
for the stars and you get to the moon
you got to the moon like as a kid I
remember her saying that and I think
that's been my competitive advantage is
like I have delusional thinking like I
really truly believe I can do these
things that are unrealistic and
and I'm only competing with people who
are also unrealistic where'd you go to
high school
this Baruch College campus high school
is like inside bro college and did you
go to college yeah I went to Santa
Barbara out here did you would you
majoring psych psych College when did
you decide to get into comedy I was I
was managing a restaurant while I went
to school and they had a comedy night
here in in in Santa Barbara okay and
like a bunch of guys like the LA guys
like I remember Sebastian coming up
performing in this [ __ ] restaurant
like I remember a bunch of guys like
remember TIG taking the taro coming and
performing like it's crazy to see you
know who's ended up blowing up from the
people that perform this shitty little
restaurant and then they asked me if I
want to try it one time and I was like
yeah I [ __ ] always love comic like I
bought the def Comedy Jam like cassettes
you know that scam way back in a day bro
you give your dad's credit card and then
they just keep on sending you these
cassettes so like we just had all these
cassettes but I was like obsessed you
know and like you know watching the
Kings of Comedy that kind of stuff like
obviously delirious and yeah I just
thought it was so cool and then they
asked me to try it I was like [ __ ]
I'll give it a try Barbara I came back
like a month later and then I just
started back up in New York and what did
it feel like when you started I just
loved it I loved it like I just loved
the problem of it like you couldn't
control anything it was like basketball
you know I grew up playing ball and like
the rim was always gonna be ten feet and
the ball was always gonna be the size of
the ball and like if I could get open I
can practice enough where I can hit that
shot you know or I can practice number I
can get by guys but with comedy was like
isn't matter how much you practice you
don't know what the [ __ ] the rim is
gonna be like that day you know what the
[ __ ] the you know ball is gonna be like
that everything changes so is like this
constant problem it's like how do I
control all these different things at
one time
I just [ __ ] loved it you know I have
an anecdote I always crack jokes like on
56 I got one foot in the grave when I'm
gonna have appeal but the truth of the
matter is I got one foot in the grave
but I'm still learning something every
day
yeah you know and it's a lot of regular
people listening to this a lot of common
people listen to this ayat a lot of
young comedians not to be in a rush and
it's a journey yeah
and the journey is the best part because
you get to find treasure that is like
life is treasure but that [ __ ] is so
hard like you know it's like you know
like every rich person says money
doesn't make you happy and every poor
person is like man once I get some money
I'm gonna be happy right it's like my
mom would say the same [ __ ] to me
because she was like three times your
ass ballroom dance champion like so in
her field she was like the best and she
would always say the journey is the best
like enjoy and I come home from sets and
bombing and just having like a long time
she's like mom listen this is the best
part of your of you this is the most
exciting and even now when I look back
on it and now I'm having all this
success like I still remember like dying
or hangouts you know I mean after spots
like just me and like the guys I started
with just [ __ ] grossed at each other
at a diner
the selca ii am like like those are the
memories that like stick with me for
some reason how long did you have a date
did you keep a day job while you were
doing drama I did I was probably not
doing I live with my parents for as long
as I could but I was probably doing a
day job for the first maybe three years
and then I just kind of lived off scraps
and then nothing and I would get like a
little gig here there and then like a
second I could you know maybe a college
gig would pop up and I would just kind
of like live off you know five bucks a
day or ten bucks a day eating falafels
for you know two three meals if I could
and then eventually some things start to
happen and then you know I got one thing
I got the next thing and I could make
just enough and if I had to rent out my
room in my apartment I would do that but
it was just how do I focus all my time
on comedy I had some savings from
working like my whole hustle of comedy
was I had some savings were working in
college and I was like I'm gonna spend
all that money and hopefully by the time
I'm at zero I'll make money doing comedy
so I just invested everything I had has
saved my whole life into learning how to
do comedy
you know I always see these people that
invest in the stock market or gamble I
always tell people he's gonna gamble
gamble on yourself yeah I've always
gambled on me
and I've always been on me and to be
honestly I've always been the underdog
yeah I've known this when I walk into
the room
ya know that's what keeps me [ __ ]
about ya know but you've taken the
hustle in a different way you got to do
it man and there's not too many people
that get the system you know you become
an open mic here you fight you fight you
fight you fight you start getting a
little bit an awesome Comedy Central or
somebody gets involved and then you
scrap you scrap then something good
happens and then you check then nothing
nothing happens for a while yeah and
you're like well my agents gonna help me
or my managers gonna help me or my
friend said at the end of the day the
only person that could help you as you
yeah you have to sit down the value is
where you are you wrap a notebook and
set out a plan that's it and stick to
that plan yeah and whether your mother
dies where your dog gets hit by a law
that thing that's executed and you do it
enough and it just becomes secondary and
next thing you know I think that 90% of
people don't stick with things because
they don't see the results yeah first
year they need it quick they need a
quick and yeah that's what this journey
taught me I had no patience I want that
[ __ ] now my grandma coke now when I
have pork fried rice now yeah it wasn't
like that but by the time I got into
Konami I was 32 and I had already been
beat up by alive and I'd already been to
prison you know so I was like if I do
this I'm gonna do this the right way I
asked a thousand questions I got a job
yeah it's like the door guy at a club
yes a thousand questions yeah I knew the
other day somebody wrote uh you know
restock your shirts you could make more
money and I'm like if I wanted to make
money yeah Cody got into selling cocaine
yeah yeah
I'll be giving ya day one I always said
there's not gonna be any money yeah and
that's what made this journey for a guy
like me even better because I'm like
everybody else yeah I was waiting to get
money to make me happy yeah you can't
get good at money that's the thing I
realize like a money isn't a skill right
so it's like I can't get good at that I
can get good at a skill and I've
realized at least wherever there's
greatness there's money like you could
be the best at darts and that
[ __ ] making money nobody that's
the best at something isn't making some
money so my feeling was like I'm just
gonna do the [ __ ] I love and money will
find it well they will find but I never
and the other thing is like I realize
like if I'm I'm kind of like maniacal
with my work I think like but I had I
loved it
so my feeling was like I'll just do this
[ __ ] that I love and then I'll work my
ass off on it and I know I can outwork
you you know even if you're better than
me or you're more gifted to me or
something like that like it just
I'll outwork you but I can only do that
if I really love it so I know I love
stand up more than anything so I don't
mind you know grinding it's as hard as I
thought like tomorrow I'm gonna stir it
tomorrow I'm gonna take a flight at
midnight to New York I land at 9:00 in
the morning I'll do two podcasts and
then I hop on a flight to Russia you
know what I mean like a lot of people
just won't do that all right people will
be like I I'm gonna be tired so I'll
just subtract tired I'll subtract a lot
of [ __ ] this [ __ ] up like friend like
I haven't seen a lot of my friends kids
it [ __ ] sucks but like there's
certain things you gotta sacrifice if
you want to be great at things you
didn't get put on this planet to beat
look at kids anyway that's for Epstein
you know that's that's that's the
honest-to-god truth yeah I've been
watching you I've been watching your
movements and stuff cuz I love watching
I love you don't learn what you learn by
watching let me see what Richard jenny's
don't let me see what this guy's doing
let me have this guy's don't oh this
guy's putting twenty thousand to a
special that he really [ __ ] and thinks
is gonna sell good luck [ __ ] oh you know
you watch and you just just figured out
your whole
game number one you're a psych major and
number two you know hoopster when you're
an old hoopster you always know one
thing that guy is practicing right now
huh that guy right now is his basketball
you can practice all day all day with me
at night I go home and sit on the wall
practice my defense on the wall and do
burpees
yeah like dribble everywhere all over
the [ __ ] house like go on the yard
and do figure eights
and I had a backboard and I do MA what
was Madden Jill it was the same two
rebounder that you just kept Rodman no
no no before him in the 50s like the
Hoosiers you think some guy had a drill
something drilling you go from one side
of the basket to the other and I do that
for three [ __ ] hours you know when
you play and that was your mentality in
basketball if you're not doing it that
other [ __ ] with it understand
you sleeping that dude is doing jumping
jacks that dude is jumping right now
working on his vertical so he could
block your [ __ ] yeah
so that was my mentality when I was a
kid yeah I'd watch a [ __ ] bat I still
gonna watch it like the old Knicks I
walk Frazier no mama wrong yeah you know
and I'd watch how war Frazier would walk
up the internet home on Raw would just
pick your pocket in those days they were
allowed to put this dinky let's say
let's say you didn't even see it
yeah let's say when the Knicks were
playing the Celtics and you you had a
cover white boy what was his name from
the southeast I'll have a check right
I'm talking to 70s they would go like
this but they would hold your shirt yeah
in a way see the ref can see that course
not you're not going nowhere
yeah that gives me a minute they would
do the dirtiest things to you yeah
shorts yeah ain't gone that's why I was
called what was it called and guarded
yeah yeah
and check you they walk in they would
take your shirt and wrap it under their
finger yeah so they really had one
finger out and three out it was [ __ ]
amazing to see like all the tricks that
you could do anyway yeah see that's the
school of thought you came from you for
sure from the sports man if he's not
doing it I'm gonna be doing it I just a
rewrite myself every night when I first
started I would rewrite it every night I
just got all that didn't work let me
change it I didn't understand in a
moment that bit like you could perform
it better I thought there was something
wrong with it so I was like I'm gonna
fix I read every single book I used to
transcribe
dude I was psycho like I would
transcribe whole specials and just try
to understand what the joke was how did
he get from here to there the premise
like I would just a specially trained uh
chappal man I was a you know obviously
Rock I'm at Red Rocks book but I was
really trying to understand like jokes
just I was like some people understand
it I was like trying to understand
opening and the value of opening and
like why it's setting a tone early can
you know lead to something and like I
would disagree with a lot of
conventional wisdom but I wouldn't
understand
why just yet you know like everybody
always say like open up agreeable and
all that kind of [ __ ] and like I always
felt in my heart that if I opened up
like nice or sweet and then I gave them
who I was who's you know kind of
challenges conventional thinking like I
always felt like I was lying to them and
they would resent that so like I learned
later on that it's like I should open up
as hard as I possibly can and a cool
piece if I can get them to laugh at that
absolutely everything else is fair game
that's it you know but it takes a lot of
[ __ ] bomb and people throwing candles
at you and [ __ ] to like get there you
know so I was like I mean I had the
coolest we had this little room in New
York the village lantern and I swear to
god the only way I could develop my
style is with a place like this they
just gave us the room and we begged
people off the street to come downstairs
but it was a place where I didn't have
to worry about getting booked next week
you know I'm saying like I I was one of
people begging strangers to come in so
along I got strangers in I could perform
and then I could actually [ __ ] be me
I wasn't like doing the cookie cutter
set so I get some more feature work at
the funny bone I was just I was bombing
but it was okay I was bombing as me I
was trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
my version of stand-up was and I don't
know how I don't know how I could
possibly do that I don't know how I
could develop the tools that I have now
if I wasn't in that type how long how
many years that take you to get onto
something it was like for me was like
flashes you ever like experience that
like ah right I go through these things
where it's like and I knew I was about
to reach something else when I would
start the bomb a lot like like I think
maybe Nate bargatze told me this was
something like I'd be doing fine doing
fine doing fine or for whatever I
thought was fine at the time and then
I'd like I'd start to do shitty and I'd
be like upset and like depressed about
it and I remember my buddy I think it
was Nate he was telling oh you just
plateauing and when you're plateauing
and you start to bomb again it means
you're about to have another leap so
every time I'll get into like a bomb
streak of that okay it's coming I don't
know when it's gonna come but there's
something about those bombs that like
bring the you a do you are you cuz
there's nothing left you get sick of it
there's nothing less signified and you
go why am i doing these cookie cutter
jokes - I'm not doing me and I'm not
giving ya you know and if I'm gonna bomb
I'm a dude is me but if I'm gonna go
down I'm gonna go down swinging I'm not
gonna let you beat me up right so and
then something in the in the going down
swinging always brings out the raw you
and I steer something about a group of
strangers when they see authenticity
it's you it's why you're electric I was
talking to Joe about this it's like they
know it's real they know it's real they
can't help but see something real and if
it's real they go along with it they'll
laugh at cute [ __ ] from someone who's
fake if it's like clever or that kind of
[ __ ] but the real laughs are when
they're when they're in front of
something that's authentic
they just can't deny it it's we [ __ ]
here yeah like I started out as Lenny
Clark I wore a suit yeah that didn't
work it wasn't you and I go laughs now
you know I would curse and the suit
wouldn't fit and then
it was just it took me like four and it
took me I dated a stripper she brought
it out he was a filthy animal she
brought yeah wouldn't make me spend my
we could do a gig 400 bucks yeah she
make technically four miles and she
dumped me then we get into a fight might
get thrown out into the street with $18
if I just bought groceries at house I'm
like and I would take like the prime
beef with me like walked away and she
bring me with mace and I was throwing
like a prime rib at oh yeah what on the
street next to Vista and between Santa
Monica Boulevard and sunset 19 May even
Mason shoot me would make I was blocking
it with the meat
swinging either with the [ __ ] meat
you ever swing at each other and after
that we're like listen man was you shoot
mace at your boyfriend did you really
break up yeah we broke up today were
great friends so I have a theory that
it's not all strippers about like I
think that strippers experience so much
[ __ ] like so many like fake
interactions with guys guys trying to
get over them guys trying to schmooze
them this like pseudo like bravado part
of a man bizzy's pain he thinks he has
some kind of like entitlement did I
think they see through [ __ ] better
than most human beings and I think that
like in a weird way if you have like a
friend of yours it's a stripper you
can't really be fake around her because
she notices it so maybe there's
something to her like exposing your
authenticity no no we would get into
fights and this one particular Monday I
went from fighting with her straight to
the open mic in Seattle and I went out
on stage and just did six minutes on her
and somebody happened to catch it on
tape
let him go going home playing and going
that's it that's the guy that's it
that's what needs to be yelling
screaming [ __ ] I was angry the jokes
were funny because of the energy the
energy was right up and you're right
after that I got bits and smatterings of
it it would cut you come and go out of
hand and then you try to replicate it
and there's no what doesn't work you try
to be angry it has to be really have to
be passionate about it
when did you start all the multi
marketing stuff I mean when I had no
other option you know I had no other
there was no other way like no no
stand-up networks or anything ever
wanted to [ __ ] with me they just all
decided early on that it wasn't gonna
happen for me so I I filmed my own
special and I was hoping I'd be able to
sell it and everybody said no and I was
like well I gotta find another way and
that's when I started really analyzing
what was wrong with stand-up what did
you pay for the first place sure if you
don't ah
20 30 grand maybe something like that
edit shot everything I mean we had that
was a really elaborate one and I did
with Manhattan production they were you
know buddies of mine and they did it for
like the cheap it could it should have
cost way more but like we had two
different I did in five different clubs
so we had two different camera teams
they were jumping from Club to club
because the idea was what would it be
like to have a night of comedy in New
York and just following a New York comic
around to these different spots but um
well yeah I just I filmed that nobody
wants to buy it so I just sat there for
a second lowest time in my comedy career
for sure you know you owe me a family I
wouldn't have bought that shitty I was
like bro I gotta figure this [ __ ]
[ __ ] out so I just started I just
started you know seeing what was wrong
with the game and how I could penetrate
the game and what I kind of figured just
from asking people everybody I asked
about comedy I would ask non comics a
big so tell me who you watch in like how
the specials and they name people and
they'd always say the same thing they go
it was funny I mean I didn't finish it
everybody said I didn't finish it and I
was like okay it's too long
is too long that's okay it's too long
number one let's talk talk on the topic
of special yeah I think that what's
going on with specials today yeah
there's a [ __ ] Horror Show yeah when
people come to me and they said they
spent between 150 yeah to thousands of
hard-earned dollars on a special I feel
like [ __ ] shooting myself it doesn't
matter if the 20 years nobody listened
to it well nobody solves anything
you could shoot your pilot you could
shoot your movie it's cute there's hope
yeah but you're not gonna because listen
you know I knew I know that least if
they want to buy it they would have they
would have if they're gonna buy it they
would have bought it before you said it
simple as that if you've got a show that
you shoot in reality it's better than
Seinfeld and you shoot it they're not
gonna buy it because you dated the shoot
they don't buy it based on how good you
are
that's the thing that these people don't
stand all over there's nothing I've been
the same good as I was before I was
doing well
and as I am now I mean obviously I've
gotten better at standing because you
progress in this art form but like I was
good back then I was worthy of having a
special nobody gave a [ __ ] you know now
wherever I go there's you know agents
from different agencies popping up to
the clubs and everybody wants to have a
conversation now you tell them go suck
my dick no no because you got to let
people convert that's what I realized no
no I understand that but now you see the
change listen I don't blame them there's
a big change
yeah you could be the funniest guy in
the world it's sequel you're not selling
the ticket it's a game I got at home
it's simple as that and I didn't know
that either when I got here 90 a little
bit more cuz we think about is getting
abouts not about kill that killing [ __ ]
is for you and me it's not about it's
not for them that's a personal thing
that you want to do all on your own
that's it I want to go give him
everything the [ __ ] I got but there's
people I see on TV others wanting some
Disney Channel my daughter and I had a
little ice house that night and it was
some [ __ ] challenge of the network
kids or something
and one of the hosts was an economic but
I knew from years ago when I watch that
showing I felt so bad
mmm he said isn't that great yeah that's
what I want to be a universal special
would be for kids I'd rather be at the
funny bone in Columbus [ __ ] swingin
dick hair up on stage rocket you know a
hundred percent but it's so weird how I
was not a I was never fair an industry
favorite yeah well I did my see so
special I was a little happy but not
really yeah what I did the Netflix
special till this day I'm disappointed
why cuz I wanted to be you okay I did
not want to cross that line if you
didn't want me like right now you go to
Netflix tomorrow and say I'm gonna do a
special human yeah I don't have me a
special right they'll give me an hour
table in Miami I could do that but I
won't
why not why would I I gotta play that
your [ __ ] boat no come see me in the
[ __ ] main room on a Tuesday night
tell me I don't deserve an hour special
so I don't argue it on that in my world
I don't give a [ __ ] about that but
you're a special guy and right now
you're a very special guy
and you're special for comedy hmm
because you're letting people know what
I tried to let people know years ago
that you don't need anybody you don't
know you don't know you don't need a
network and especially in today's
climate with YouTube and social media
and whatever I'm not saying that you're
gonna be listen if you want to do comedy
for a year and put your videos up and
get them to boogie as a headliner and
then [ __ ] Steve Simone goes in there
in front of you and level stage in front
of you and you don't get ever booked
again and then you can't go nowhere God
put you but I'm saying when people start
to tell you you're really making the
difference and you go on a time schedule
every day every second Monday I'm gonna
put 15 minutes that means if you're
gonna put
fifteen minutes out of [ __ ] bed we
knew Monday everyone Monday a month you
got to work that that takes work that
see and minutes takes work if you commit
to yourself to put a 15 minutes special
up every three months
that's an hour a year well it's a lot
after eight of them people gonna start
paying attention to you I cannot stress
more what you just said I think the
illusion is that if you just put some
clips up that it works I mean to push it
in perspective like in the last seven
months I've released four hours worth of
stand-up i watch crowd work it was great
Thank You Man I appreciate the way you
shot it now what is something like that
caution issue I mean that's nothing
that's like I have I have I have my
video guy Alex Alex media shouts at Alex
media and you know he's my full-time
video guy and I got another comic that's
on the road with me Marc Gagnon it also
does video and editing stuff and we
basically have this team it's the three
of us and we you know we brought five
cameras down there and we're just like
yo let's just shoot it and see what the
[ __ ] we get and that's how I think
comedy should be done like I don't think
you should put all this pressure to like
doing this thing at one time getting
that one title right there you [ __ ] that
like film a bunch and Jews what's [ __ ]
good you know it's like you want I want
my most natural moment like for you if
I'm capturing a special with you I don't
even want you to know I'm filming like
the way I would I don't want you to know
I know I'd hide the camera for a whole
[ __ ] weekends I don't want you and
then and then I'd go I go to you at the
end of week and I bake you know II by
the way remember that set that you did
in the main room blah blah yeah you
[ __ ] demolish so we got that on video
you want us to release that as your
special and you watch and you're like
holy [ __ ] this is the draw this is
natural it's not you looking at the
camera to make sure I never tell the
audience and I'm filming because I don't
want to put that in their [ __ ] head I
want a real organic moment between comic
and audience you know and that's I think
that's a lot of times the difference
between the clips you know like that we
put out and that kind of stuff like I'm
not putting out only jokes I put out
some crowler's
I said put out the crowd work special
but like I'm just kind of trying to
capture these raw organic moments that
we have and we put out a [ __ ] a lot
of it but that's what I need to do to
compete with a billion-dollar company
I'm basically out here just going like
yo we should be able to have a lane for
us so if you're a comic and you want to
put the work in please do whatever I did
it's a blueprint for you if there's one
thing that I comedies been great for me
there's one thing I can give back to
comedy hopefully it's a little bit of
freedom for comics too you know who
might not have had an opportunity to
make one for themselves but what comics
don't understand what people don't
understand in life is whether your
realtor
a comedian is you make your own path
understand
you want to believe like I love these
guys that go hey I'm starting a new
podcast mm-hmm I'm starting with blah
blah blah and then a [ __ ] push it for
me now that's gonna push it sorry
yeah I can just see another doomsday
coming there's another Duma who believe
that somebody's gonna push him you
believe that this network can't even
push their own TV shows I'm gonna learn
how to push a [ __ ] podcast and then
when nothing happens they're like I
don't know I happened because where the
[ __ ] were you you know thing I've been
doing the same thing for the last 10
years I got up at 6 and I hit social
media early but I invent that know a guy
by the name of Howard Stern invented I
guess copied there you go and may that's
all we're doing is watching what works
for ya and putting it together yeah I
don't have you know millions so all
these guys they shoot that $203,000
special if you get to a place to shoot a
special and they got a camera boom I
don't want to do it you just took the
organic miss out of the [ __ ] room
dude think about this have you ever seen
a nice beautiful shot in a special and
that shot made you laugh no what the
[ __ ] is the point of this special what
have you ever you sit at a comedy club
right
not every seat is good some there's a
[ __ ] beam blocking half-assed
age who gives a [ __ ] this idea that a
commie special got to look like the VMAs
it don't think it has to look like a
comedy club there you got to feel like
you're in the [ __ ] Club
you got a it's got to sound like it like
people people try to make the audio of
the mic sound so good and it's like the
audio should sound good you should hear
what the person saying but you also
gotta feel the crowd all these specials
out there sound like the comics bombing
it's like the crowd plays part of it
make the person at home feel like
they're in that [ __ ] crowd like I
love the concept of the podcast so much
why is that because I wanted to make
people started listening yeah I think we
forgot how to listen I see it in humans
yeah we don't listen every day you could
tell from which I'm dead time
yeah and I'll come back to you wrong man
you know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] we
just say yeah we don't listen
yeah we don't pay attention that's why I
love the podcast because it's unedited
wrong yeah I could say the one we we
those you come on this [ __ ] podcast
and you say something you call me an
hour later and said take it out this is
what we're not radio yeah I don't do
nothing
yeah it's us having a [ __ ]
conversation yeah when I grew up I grew
up where you put in you put in was it
something I said was the [ __ ] crazy
the album would be a little warp yeah
and he would listen to it yeah surprise
jokes would be a little walk you still
left and you still had a good time and
then in 1977 which you probably put out
a special with the [ __ ] chalkboard
behind them with a menu that had dailies
a hamburger ten cents of french fries
and I thought it was the most brilliant
thing I'd ever saw and stand up one of
the first tapes I got into it I evolved
into yeah after I started stand-up and
started watching it was that Richard
Pryor special yeah and what gravitated
me to it was the fact that he was in
front of us a menu yeah they didn't have
a [ __ ] curtain yeah well brick wall
was shiny lights here and just showed up
to a place and they just tape them
it became a [ __ ] special yeah you
know when these agents and managers say
well I've had 20 managers tell me well
look at the leap very special it wasn't
shot right what are you talking about
ended up an HBO shut the [ __ ] up
well look at that special it was the
shop right it ended up on this [ __ ]
thing just have a good idea shut the
[ __ ] up and Netflix don't want you
listen okay so you're gonna be all right
you're gonna be all right
if [ __ ] what's the other one that's
doing it now Amazon Amazon don't worry
yeah you're gonna be all right yeah if
Comedy Central don't watch it you're
gonna be all right why because you got a
notebook
you got a stage you got a camera mm-hmm
and you got YouTube yeah you got YouTube
Instagram you got Twitter I mean for it
we're comics we should be trying to make
money on the road that's the way I look
at it like I've never made money from a
special so now I have the most leverage
going into any negotiation cuz you can't
take anything away from me right it's
not like I'm one of these guys that I
need to put a special out every year
because my mortgage is paid by the
special it's not my mortgage just paid
by the road so when I go into
negotiation someone's like well we'll
give you $25,000 for you to do this on
Netflix I'll be like well I think I'm
worth more than that and this is the
number I think I'm worth and then that's
nothing is gonna be lower than that
because I'm fine without it
you gotta protrude generous yeah what
they do they ask you yeah are you
turning down yeah good but not that I
not that I was against it cuz my theory
is I don't have anything against Netflix
I post my stuff on Twitter on Instagram
on YouTube like I'm not against posting
on Netflix either my whole theory with
it was I'm gonna if I do do it I'll post
I'll you know people will go see it on
on Netflix and then they'll look for
more of my [ __ ] on Netflix and there
won't be any more and then they're gonna
go okay well where else can we see him
and they'll YouTube me and then I just
converted all those people to my YouTube
subscribers and that's way more power
for me so I wasn't against it but I got
another offer that came in it was
significantly higher
so I was like okay that's closer to what
I'd be interested in I I watched the lab
work special not come I came to LA as a
post-reduction person and it's
everything had to match and anyway if
you're shooting two different shows you
want you don't want people to know sure
and the thing I found interesting about
your special was is that there are a few
moments where you can tell that it just
you went from one place to another yeah
and what we were what you guys are
talking about is in your head when
you're editing let go they're gonna
freak them out in two seconds later you
enter into the next joke they don't care
they don't they want to be entertained
they're not they didn't come that late
for post-production right you did your
artists so that's your art so you're
looking at every brush stroke you're
like ah man that you know van Gogh
didn't well do that [ __ ] but the average
person listening is having a [ __ ]
tough day they just came back from
working a [ __ ] shitty job and they
want 35 minutes of distraction from an
annoying [ __ ] day and if you can
provide that there's no way in hell
they're gonna go I would have adjusted
the light a little bit and that you know
second bit right okay they really don't
care if the idea is there it speaks to
it like I think most people were into
watching because they're like he's just
gonna do 35 minutes on the stage and not
bring any jokes he's just gonna like
riff and [ __ ] with the crowd for 35
minutes
okay I'll [ __ ] with that I think they
were just curious in the idea and that's
what I always try to with every special
I put out there's an agenda and and with
this one it was like everybody keeps
saying that you know we're so sensitive
and we can't laugh at anything and I'm
like that's [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] it's it
is [ __ ] nonsense dude the whole
special is shot so you can see the
audience and you see obviously me and my
crowd is probably the most diverse crowd
in comedy and yours the mexican chick
the indian took the black chicks the
black dudes the [ __ ] like that every
religion is just getting [ __ ] roasted
and they're laughing at themselves and
you cannot be triggered by the special
because you're not gonna be offended on
behalf of this dude who wasn't offended
about the joke about him so my whole
feeling was instead of telling people
not to be offended I'm just gonna show
you this is America right here nobody's
offended five minutes you goof another
Korean guy No
so listen you will mail from a certain
place and obviously your parents are
immigrants and you see that I'm I'm
never gonna [ __ ] change or [ __ ] I am
the other sandmen I'm never gonna change
who the [ __ ] I am
last thing I was telling people about my
little personal things I just stopped
talking to you like if you eat margarine
well I gotta talk a little more if you
dip your [ __ ] buffalo wings and ranch
we can't talk long you know there's a
lot of things that we just don't need to
talk yeah you're off the [ __ ] marker
you know do you you just done you're
doing so many things that I believed in
so long if you build it they will come
acts you know if you have 22 videos like
they said you keep continuing and I see
what you're doing on social media
brother i watch it you're doing on
social media and you're luring a man and
whatever try and sure this yeah a punk
when it came and said well why don't you
pantry on it cuz you like for five
dollars yeah I got a different yeah
you're making it short money it's short
money it's like we have a three on for
the Pat for the podcast right but like
for clips and that kind of stuff again
the long the long game gets bigger
psyche effect comedy like when I see
I'll be honest when I see you know
Chappelle's special sticks and stones
right and like the the topic material
he's going after and like what he's
doing like part of me gets is really
proud because I know we've been railing
on that on YouTube for like you know a
few years now and it's like oh [ __ ]
we were right like we were right two
years ago when we decided [ __ ] this or
three years ago whatever it [ __ ] his PC
nonsense the people want real comedy
let's go out there and do it and then
when you see the biggest comedian in the
game you know and he goes and echoes a
lot of these these same things it's like
yeah that's right we know what we don't
we're not [ __ ] around this was when I
saw sure pal was coming out with a loser
I was like how good could it be you know
like how good could it be could it be
better than what they put to optimism
what I really enjoy yeah
the belly room what do you get above
yeah this one he hit it out of the park
yeah how much you're watching this and
you're hearing these things listen I'm
not to eat to treat listen I decided
that 15 years ago and calmly was I saw
the only [ __ ] comics I saw leave this
town because they're like well when I
write material I write material so the
networks could see the show you already
lost
you just lost ya already lost you just
lost I do grandma jokes because I want
to paint the picture so when the network
come to see me you're done I knew that
15 [ __ ] years I've been here 23 years
I knew that yeah 16 years ago I said
it's over
no no story go ahead first time I went
to Montreal that's what that was my
thinking I did might as well just for
laughs and I did the new faces and I had
some jokes that I thought were like
really funny and really good job Mulaney
better [ __ ] take this suit off and
then I switched it because I was like oh
this would probably make a better show
or whatever I thought that you're
supposed to have as a comment I don't
even want to sitcom but like I thought
since I was a comic that you're supposed
to want it that's when I switched it and
I didn't do well and I and I [ __ ]
bombed have to set the first time and
like I just did not have a good new
faces and I didn't go back for years and
eventually I started selling tickets and
they brought me back and then this last
year I went back and I did
nasty show and I was really doing well
and they asked me to do this Jaisal net
gala and I had given him an asset that I
was going to do for the Jazz on that
gala and the day before the gala I said
[ __ ] that I'm not gonna do that said no
and I just went up and I did whatever I
felt in that moment I didn't even have a
set list
I was just like whatever jokes feel that
they're the right thing to do and I got
a standing ovation girl and it was just
this moment where it was like trust your
[ __ ] guts stop trying to please these
suits
stop trying to please these execs you do
what you want to do and you fail until
it works and I promise you if you can
keep doing it long enough it will work
out most people can't suffer that long
but if you can it will work out I don't
know what I'm gonna say I get there then
and that's why they like it even then
you got a problem but dude that that's
why I like with your special like I
don't want to see you walking onstage if
I'm watching your special I gotta I
gotta come in to you already going does
that make sense like for me I'm the
guest at your house not that moment
where the comic walks and through the
curtains and eka no no you're already
moving I see I should hear your voice
already going and you're talking about
this don't you got a monkey and it this
that and then like the camera comes
through the doors
and you're there is it you're I'm saying
because that's your comfort zone your
comfort zone is us in your house it's
your show you don't I mean not like okay
time to turn it on ya know it's uh what
they preach and what you do after I shot
the Netflix degenerates we'll just when
it's all came to me yeah and here I'm
doing comedy 26 years yeah it all came
to me I'm like that's it yeah I'm doing
something I'm going out with a different
type of bad let's do something man what
are they gonna do yeah yeah [ __ ] now
another thing that you're doing that's
very intelligent is let's be honest I
got a wife when I sit down to watch a
special light I become a consumer mm-hm
you got about six minutes that's it
and if you pass that six minutes the
honest opinion if this is Jesus and
you're killing I'm still probably gonna
shut you off 428 go do something but I
need to know why I sit there and catch
myself going this song I gotta be
divorced just to the city like a
movement or yeah you're an adult do
something and then you come back and you
finished it I have to be honest to you
they should file special I tolerated for
38 minutes I went and did something than
a night later I came back and watched it
and then I watched it over two nights
back-to-back and that's when it sunk in
well he had done what something you were
gonna start saying earlier you did
you're special at 35 minutes and you've
noticed that when you watch as special
as you've been you yeah
even if you know your pal Wilbur Theo
von yeah at 28 your dude I had to earn
35
I didn't deserve 35 minutes of your
attention imagine a stranger walked up
to you and he was like hey you want to
listen me for 35 minutes did someone go
[ __ ] himself
Yeah right like I it took me years to
earn 35 minutes of your attention
I started at 15 and then I just put up
clips the clips were anywhere from like
two minutes to maybe nine minutes and I
would do that every week and then I then
I put another special out but those
clips are around seven eight minutes
each but you could watch them together
and then even then you'd cap it around
32 minutes but I slowly built up your
tolerance for me because who the [ __ ]
was I I was a nobody nobody knew who I
was so I needed to slowly build you up
to who I was and then once you really
trusted me and you loved my stand-up you
loved my perspective and I give you
thirty five minutes you're happy you're
like oh [ __ ] it's not just ten we get 35
it's a treat not a chore and I always
want our art to be a treat not a chore I
never want you to feel forced with
comedy I never want you to feel like
you're bullied into it you know you must
stay to the end well guys our nothin bro
it's an honor to stay to the end that's
what it should be that's why never
really sold shapes after a show
yeah I always felt that I already
tortured you enough
come over shake my hand and don't shake
my hand yeah but they want the shirt man
what they want the shirt they [ __ ]
love you go on go online by the [ __ ]
shirt I don't want to I want you to come
talk to me like a man if I had like I
don't like adding a second show some
nights because the globe will say you
sold out yeah you can't go out there
they have nowhere to go you know yeah
that bothers me yeah because I want to
talk to him I want to see what's on
their mind with me I come and tell me I
got all foxy Gardens because of you yeah
I started [ __ ] my girlfriend they
asked more because tell me what's going
on with their lives
yeah but I always felt you have no idea
I watched you know I'm a fan and I'm
like yeah tell you know Jean Perret is
Jean Grey he's a writer he had work
books on how to write Tommy you know I'd
do everything I'm uh I'm uh I'm I was a
student of the game
yeah it's just didn't [ __ ] happen
yeah I just didn't go on youtube and
crack a joke yeah come to my shows yeah
I wanted to bad nothing else I had no
parents no [ __ ] money no relationship
yeah you know so I I had nowhere else to
go I was like Richard Gere doors to the
gentleman yeah yeah so I had to dive
into this you know but I've had beliefs
over the years which specials you know
social media you you're one of the few
people that I'm really enjoying your
journey because you're proving my
perspective to myself cuz they knew it I
knew it
first of all we have listen if you came
to LA in 1998 you had an audience you
know your audience was a day three hours
yeah 8:00 to 11:00
that's your audience you know the
date-time hosts are you know so unless
you showed up on [ __ ] NYPD Blue or
whatever you have three hours a day for
them to catch you from 8:00 to 11:00 now
I got Andrew short 24/7 if I wake up at
4:00 in the morning and I have insomnia
I can put on shelters podcast whatever's
35 minutes specials yeah it don't cost
me nothing whatever the [ __ ] it's there
that's the brilliant thing that you know
I gotta be out of you it's pretty tough
while you have work to click on kinetics
click onto the app penny I'll put on a
different page and listen to somebody
it's Netflix it's it's a visual but you
know what even with YouTube I believe
now that your audience is from 6:00 in
the morning the [ __ ] 11:00 at night
later
they could watch yet so later you put a
clip up at 11 o'clock at night and you
wake up in this 90 thousand comments
that's all from England and [ __ ]
Romania and [ __ ] bird you know
yeah Australia New Zealand cool how
[ __ ] is watching videos at this time
[ __ ] yeah so it's become your 24/7
your accessible 24/7 and shareable but
and Sheryl that's the big thing what the
highlight is 8 to 5 yeah 8 to 5 is a
huge window come here to 8 to 11 at
night so people going to work they get
their work they click onto YouTube when
I'm Andrew and they go on their page and
they giggle why they watch that's it
Andrew and that to me
I knew the same thing all I needed to do
was tell my story yeah I was just
waiting to tell my story I know
eventually there was going to be
something some wake in the system that I
could tell my story and that's what
separated me from the rest of these
[ __ ] you know but you needed a
place that was uncensored because some
of our stories are better uncensored
yeah no no there's no Centurion while so
it's like you and I we needed a YouTube
to exist for us you know like we they're
a bunch of us that needed that freedom
so that you could get the authentic
version of us and that's why we tend to
thrive in this open free market whereas
like cornballs tends to thrive in the
closed market you know when there is
only Comedy Central HBO doing stand-up
it was like well you better be in one of
those lanes because if not you don't do
stand-up simple as that and there are a
lot of people that just did not fit in
either of those lanes and you know thank
God that we got this new like now you
got no excuse man now it's like you know
in high school you got to like kind of
fit into some guru
or you're by yourself and then you go to
college and it's like oh [ __ ] I can
choose my friends that's the Internet
the Internet is you do your [ __ ]
comedy people will find you you like
talking about rats and [ __ ] or knives or
potions [ __ ] that like rats
knives and potions are gonna find your
comedy and be like y'all that's the guy
that's who I [ __ ] with the rat potion my
dude I love that guy I just believe that
man hundred percent but it's funny
because years ago if you had YouTube
you didn't people had a scroll by you
that look for you yeah you know they had
a bump into you now you could lead them
there yeah social media little by little
little by little and I'm super lucky too
because like I did a podcast with
Charlemagne to God and I still do one
brilliant idiots where like he's one of
the most you know famous people on the
planet so I got a lot of eyeballs
through him and then of course going on
Rogen's podcast and the fighter and the
kid and like seeing those massive
audiences obviously yours now it's like
new people can see me because other
people who support me like I'm not
saying this is just me like I'm built on
a foundation of like a million comedians
before me and friends of mine that
happen to have immense power and
influence but like what I realized is if
you're true to the game people who are
true to the game will help you everybody
who's true to the game gets a shot you
know like if if you're a real one other
real ones notice and they go this guy's
good we need to get behind this guy I
never asked to be on anybody's podcast
right it was people who I just put out
the work and I trusted that if I cared
about the [ __ ] work and I cared about
comedy it will be evident of that the
people with power will go yo man come on
a podcast I think people need to hear
what you what's going on with you and I
guess maybe that's I don't know at least
that's what it seemed like for me it's
just it's like by focusing on the game
other you know everything just kind of
comes together you know I think I follow
you on twitter and before you on Rogen I
had watched a couple of your clips yeah
and I'd seen the amount of views you
were gettin I'm like this kids on to
something and then you popped up on
rogue and ran your name was Schultz and
then when I went back to shoot the
soprano
move you reached out you were gentlemen
you're like you know you're in my city
and I take you out to lunch yeah I
started watching you a little more and
then last week I read the interrobang
article yeah that guy he's good guy
I will send a shout-out to an carol bang
they do great work yeah they care about
comedy and he you know listen twenty
years ago you came here Comedy Central
didn't like you you had to go to therapy
good therapy because that a girl beard
you you had nothing you had no option
you know and yeah you could shoot you
special now it's like you said there's
really no excuses you go out there
whatever you wanna be a drummer whatever
but you have to stick with it see that's
the problem
yeah people do something for nine months
or didn't work out who gives a [ __ ]
stick with it do it for 18 months do it
for the wall man now I'm getting 50 hits
on my okay then do it for another
mindless man
you were right I'm getting it was crazy
because people want to go from zero to a
million yeah and it's like oh they want
to go viral business this video will go
viral unless you got a dog who lights
his ass on fire you you got a chance to
go viral like chlamydia viral you're
doing a joke about a [ __ ] dog getting
killed right now you know it's it's it's
also your expectations listen your
expectations in this game like I said
I'm in LA 23 years I've seen stars yeah
come and go guys that walked into the
store surround the batery Jews yeah an
assistant carrying his purse yeah and
they were gonna be stars and they want
to spill out for follow dice by mistaken
and their ego fell apart you never saw
him again and then you see him eight
years later with a kid ugly wife is bad
and now he sells real estate and Canoga
Park yeah you know because but he was
gonna be a star
yeah you even went to [ __ ] Mel's him
a couple nights and he told you how
Mahendra
I saw that Hollywood sign I knew it was
calling my name I mean people really
don't know they come out here with these
expectations and this happens and every
feel that happens in law
it happens with being a police officer
what your expectations of something of
what truly it means to me that that
expectations are the killer expert page
they had a [ __ ] killer man just enjoy
the work that's what I that's what I try
to do whenever I'm I'm I realize
whenever I'm depressed as because I care
too much about the outcome instead of
the work right like whenever I'm looking
at my phone looking to see how many
views something god or whatever like the
views validate if it was good or not you
know like that's when I'm my most
depressed or most sad or most just
unhappy when I'm at my happiest is when
I've created great work and I don't give
a [ __ ] about what happens after I put it
out all I can all I can like control is
the work once I push you know send or
upload or whatever that button is that's
out of my control so if you love it cool
man if you don't love it that's cool too
nobody's gonna love everything you're
very happy-go-lucky guy you're how long
have you been doing comedy I think about
12 years now 13 years man coming up on
13 hold it take the start clicking this
I mean man I don't even know dude it's a
long see what the Montreal the first
that was I don't know maybe five seven
years ago somebody time and you'd think
that you didn't do well I I wasn't ready
for it and then okay yeah and you really
tighten up your game and yeah I was it I
just didn't have a day I wasn't I wasn't
who I was yet like I had a little chops
and [ __ ] I could get it done but I
wasn't who I was yet like you know like
you know when like you're not ready if
you get rattled by no reactions here a
bit because you're faking it you know
I'm saying like you're faking it because
if you're if the reaction is is the only
thing you're saying for you don't
believe in it right but I knew I was
ready or I know I was ready because I I
know a joke is ready because you cannot
at all and I'd be like all right
[ __ ] just wait you guys alright
you gonna you wanna slow play me on this
[ __ ] just sit right there you stupid
[ __ ]
and then eventually okay now they're
coming in now they're coming in but I'm
not flapping cuz now it's ready the bid
is ready or I'm connected to the bid you
know I'm saying it's uh you're free man
you're a free guy and a lot of people
don't know it they're free you've gone
beyond borders you don't care about the
rules you know how come there's no rules
me and little guy you're looking at
somebody I don't give a [ __ ] I know the
rules because we're just going like when
I got into comm yelling I didn't want to
be Kevlar yeah and I hope he's
recovering my yeah Church podcast goes
out there I saw I had surgery and
whatnot I didn't want to be Kevin Hart
David Chappelle I just wanted to survive
yeah I didn't want to sell drugs I
didn't want to go back to prison
man but I fell in love with something
I studied something and then I started
looking at it from I saw how Jay Davis
years ago would pack out room you know
it wasn't just jail but there was a
couple handful of comics that were
packing our local rooms well they had
the balls to go out pass out flyers and
go out and do social media
I know and then finally one day I'm like
I better start [ __ ] around with this
computer and they changed my world you
know but again I watch the computer i
watch Twitter and see you on Twitter
today you know there's people who just
socially social network to death yeah
you and I do it very calculated for your
very calculator and I really that's a
big part of being a comic today yeah you
know when I came here I watched how
comics would go out half the year they
want a TV show for a little while they
were in town
out yeah you tore the special I get into
it all of a sudden now I'm starting to
sell tickets and it's not like that
these agents just put y'all around I
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] skateboard mm-hmm
and one week you're in date and then two
weeks later you're in Cleveland you're
like so they're giving you the recipe
for failure hmm it's until you grab bull
by the horns and go I'm doing it like
Sinatra our Sinatra my [ __ ] won't
give a [ __ ] let's go
I don't sound you don't say yeah I do
this my way I don't care about you know
right now I'm sitting in I'm like well I
was disappointed for two minutes I
didn't hear back from Netflix yeah like
that's how disappointed I was great
company they gave me a great opportunity
I'm not a friend of mine had an
expression growing up and he used to
always say sometimes it's better to want
than to have when I when I got the call
for the degenerate special I just agreed
to it I didn't think it out right it
really pissed me off that would be so
careless at the age of 55 right I've
been careless all my life man I thought
out every [ __ ] move you know well I
heard that it was being shot in a pool
you know there was just so many things
that weren't Who I am right
well I didn't give a [ __ ] I had my mouth
open like one of those Michael Jackson
accusing I was going to Australia and I
was staying next to him I sympathize
with those Michael Jackson yeah accusers
because cuz he wanted it one minute you
want yeah suck a dick on the way yeah
Harvey Weinstein in my world yeah I go
to break he might go to jail if you if
he raped somebody I want Harvey
Weinstein right jail yeah but unless you
lived in LA you won't send Harvey one
st. to go to jail yeah because people
will there's a woman out there that's 26
that's gorgeous and she will get on
their hands and knees
suck a sixty-year-old [ __ ] that tastes
like death
tastes like that I mean you know I mean
I smell my dick sometimes it smells just
[ __ ] god-awful at 56
I can't imagine what woman would you
know suck a dick to get put in a movie
it will be done out here Oh be an
oscar-winning shortcut it's a short yeah
it's a shortcut
people love shortcut I don't even blame
them I don't know you cannot blame them
cuz they don't care about the art they
just want to be famous and so you're
just gonna do whatever makes you famous
and what happened to me was when they
called and said yeah likes Netflix it
was like Netflix you'd be so lucky
yeah it was until I got there that I
said I don't think this alright yeah I
didn't think this out right and then I
went onstage and in a bag of dicks yeah
that was even more pissed off cause it's
like if I may eat one you're gonna be on
my side yeah yeah yeah yeah and there
was people that call it that said of you
watched your uncle joy walking off you
could see he was mad I was livid yeah I
was livid I had my friends and my family
there so I really couldn't blow chance
and act like a [ __ ] gorilla yeah like
I would have been 23 I went back to my
room then didn't [ __ ] sleep yeah and
it's like I knew all the mistakes I had
made I hadn't made a mistake by taking
it yeah six week notice yeah you gotta
get a set ready man when this guy tells
me cuz I love you comedy except when
you're working on something yeah and
it's the truth that will shoot me when I
know I'm getting shot I don't want to
live on a matching shirt I don't want to
[ __ ] die my hair
I don't want to put on makeup that's not
a special yeah especially I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing that's how
you get something special that's what's
special I film every show on the road
for that reason cuz I don't know what's
gonna happen at each show
so we film every show we'll film five
shows six shows seven or eight shows on
it on a weekend hoping that we get one
two-minute clip think about how crazy
that is
but we do it because that one two-minute
clip or five-minute clip is electric I
mean there was there was a moment where
there was some guy in the audience who
had clearly murdered someone and I was
roasting them not knowing that he
murdered someone and then it kind
comes out that he murdered and I can't
back off now you mean because then I'm
[ __ ] so I got a you know keep going we
gotta find it's like that can never be
recreated so we got to film every show
to get that clip everyone and that's I
think where you end up getting the magic
I think I think when you're just trying
to crunch numbers and trying to bring
all these big [ __ ] cranes production
executive I think that now if there's
one thing that I may be helped out with
comedy is like assured in the
expectations of the viewer the viewer is
fine with a comedy club now that's where
all of us put our clips and I think
that's where you know I may be put out
there in the world that that's where
comedy should be seen so now that it's
okay to do in a comedy club not a
[ __ ] Carnegie Hall can't stand that
just put let them go
don't tell anybody did they do have a
greatest specials of Dangerfield's oh I
mean they're doing a great specials at
then give me several it ain't no real
several and it's like a net club sucks
today bro nobody in there oh comfortable
they're like sagged back in the sequence
it's that such nice people you wanna
know what Weinstein's dick smells like
go go to Dangerfield I love take a whiff
of every couch every time I go to me you
go no danger sad yeah it's a different
cultural I there's a different time
where do you work out um I work out it
at a New York Comedy Club and the Comedy
Cellar those are the two main places
that I'll go to and New York Comedy Club
has two clubs now and they're just
[ __ ] killing it man they're doing so
good obviously that's not one yeah
fourth Street right I could go and then
there's my favorite isn't one on 24th
and it's a little black box room
I mean seats tops hundred people but
like for me it's you can connect to
every single person in the room you're
in the back corner if somebody picks up
their cell phone to like look text
message so I'm in the back corner I can
snap and a like everybody's locked in
and that's what I love most especially
I'm working out cuz I don't know where
the beats are yet so I can't have you
guys getting distract and everything
like that
let's let's we're gonna go through this
together I just [ __ ] love working out
how are you doing the road a lot these
days yeah man it's been good
every week I was doing almost every week
for a while I was doing almost every
week for a while and then October I'll
probably take a chill I'll go Moscow and
we got Australia and then and then we
come back and you know do these theatres
and the theaters are awesome don't get
me wrong it's like an amazing like honor
to be able to do the theatres you know
but there is part of it that gets lost
in this these big theaters right it's
like I like doing it - listen I mean I
got a kid you want to come back I don't
like this again I just I don't have I
don't have what I had 20 years ago I
don't have four weekend I know I guess I
wish I could go out the 16 weekends I
know I can come up with a new hour I get
it every [ __ ] 32 weeks you got I
don't blame you that is a dream of mine
I just yeah I still when we're going I
got no time yeah and you wanted a role
for you we should come back with 30
minutes bro it is so dude and it's it's
like you said the journey like I
remember when I released views from
assist the last special right we stagger
to release our release one piece every
week for like six weeks I had I had
maybe 15 minutes of material that wasn't
in the special so it would but I had
shows booked so it was like I need to
fill 30 [ __ ] minutes and that's where
the crowd work special comes from is I
was forced to go to sold-out shows on
the road and like you better be funny
like we've been waiting for a while for
you to come to Orlando and it was like
okay I gotta make this a [ __ ] event
and you know what do they say it's like
what is it a adversity introduces a man
to himself you know so it's like put in
that situation it was like okay I got to
come up with an hour I gotta figure this
[ __ ] thing out and and yeah we did it
man see I don't want to do that I don't
know somebody would call me and say okay
you're gonna shoot a special February 18
yeah that rule I chose to release it
though that it was March oh that's what
I want to do
I want to just put a camera tape and go
you know we're going to talk ideas for
you man what it's not what this is what
a [ __ ] work right now yeah and you
know what man I tell you what I don't
want to put this special on YouTube I
always said it put a special on YouTube
you get two million hits maybe YouTube
will do the next special with you and
even like you could get an advertiser
for this podcast to sponsor it that's
what I'm trying to like open people's
mind to it's like if I got you know I
think we're over five hundred thousand
views already in in less than a week for
for the crowd work special you know I
mean like that hits a million like I
could talk to advertisers it's like you
you pay X amount of dollars to have you
know Jimmy Fallon's audience which is
smaller than a million watch his show
for one advertisement it's like now this
you could pay my devout fans and we know
that there are certain things that are
like you could target them with
something put the money up what do you
want for a million people they [ __ ] with
me heavy to see your brand what does
that mean I mean cuz once we start doing
that once we start going direct to the
advertiser [ __ ]
it's over it's like we don't need
anybody we literally need nobody
we need HBO and Netflix etc because
they're the ones that have the money but
once we get the money to wreck and
nobody's chopping it why would you go
anywhere else why would you go anywhere
else does it make any sense yeah I think
I mean I was part of reason why I
dropped the same day as Chappelle like I
released the same day Chappelle cuz I
was I was like that's a 20 million
dollar special and I wanted to put out
especially it was zero million dollars
and I wanted you to watch them
back-to-back and I wanted you to tell me
I want to true I want you to truly watch
him back to back and then just like wit
did I laugh twenty million dollars more
it's brilliant [ __ ] I just I wanted to
sell coke to my school I tried to sell
weed when I was in Spain man but I
wasn't gonna do deliver papers and
grammar schools no but my parents just
worked their [ __ ] asses off man -
yeah
my folks my dad just works in filete
listen listen there's people look
relentlessly dude the beauty about
comedy yeah like me and we were talking
last night I wanted I got I know you do
call me every day yeah the first day is
you do call me every day
yeah then I think I did comedy every
night for the first 13 years so I got
the longest yard
I did comedy everything yeah I didn't
know what else you did yeah you just do
cops yeah and then you start doing
different things and it basically takes
you about 10 to 12 years to figure out
how to work smart we spin our wheels we
really didn't yeah you know what I call
you glaze what are you doing listen I
got a gig up in Yonkers that pays $22
yeah I got a gig at the 5th Street
Tomica and by the time you going Yonkers
you're like what the [ __ ] like give me a
softer I'll never do this again yeah
you'll do it but you'll never do it
again
sure so what I tell people is that you
learn how to work smart yeah I'm still
working 60 hours a week instead of 70
mm-hmm but it's 60 hours that's 60 hours
I have it's not spinning your wheels the
first 10 years of comedy no matter what
I'd say the first eight years account
mean it's not like useful in your wheel
there's there's uh I think a lot of
people often get confused with like
doing a set and like as if that's work
you know cuz a lot of people back I went
up tonight I did some work or like I I
tried to forward my career it's like did
you did you did you do the same jokes
you know work because in my mind I think
you just work on your ego which is
necessary we all need like a really good
show every once a while to like make
sure that we feel like we're supposed to
do it but like there's a lot of other
work that could happen you know it's
like did you try out that new bit did
you try that the new tag I would be so
upset at myself if I didn't prepare
something for the set that I did like I
just did the set that kills and didn't
add a tag or like think about a new joke
or forgot to do I was like I just
[ __ ] wasted that set because let's be
honest and my boy Chrissy D point is out
to me
the waitresses are making more money
than us at the club like when we're
doing spots in the city whether it's at
the store to improv the cellar New York
Comedy Club the wait staffs make you
more money than us so if you're not
working on your act you're losing money
my uber costs more there and back then
I'm gonna make it the club so I got to
do something outside of just work on the
bits I know work to get for it to be
worth my money right like I'm at a point
in my career where like just getting up
in a club doesn't validate me like I you
know I'm selling out theaters right so
it's like this is for me to work on bits
that there if I'm not working on [ __ ]
and I'm not trying to get better at
jokes in even if it's tweak in the order
of one little thing add in sang if I
don't add something when I go up in the
city I wasted that [ __ ] set and I
took that set away from a young comic
this should be doing it cuz what the
[ __ ] should I be doing
I should be taking some young comics
time so I can stroke my ego
the same way it's so funny I just go on
Tuesdays Thursdays and Saturdays man and
I try to do two sets in the comic so I
don't have time to drive all around the
city I know I really you know it works
so I wanted this [ __ ] metal sharpens
metal there we go after the Netflix
debacle metal sharpens metal I'm gonna
go to the store but I'm gonna work it
differently I'm gonna do a different set
in the original different sent the
mainland both lights done I'm gonna if I
go on a main room with that joke didn't
work I'm gonna tweak it before I go on
the original or vice versa I'm working
you know once a month if I'm I don't
want to go on the road every month I
love looking at my daughter I've seen a
lot of people who have spun their lives
on the road the road is turned out to be
a it could be a road to something or a
road to nowhere I want it to be to gain
momentum little spots you don't need to
go out January [ __ ] 11th they haven't
gotten their [ __ ] credit cards it's
like I'm saying there's weeks that you
just fight against the wind
yeah you know this weekend if you're a
comic and you're late but they I I
applaud you yeah
if you took the week but ain't nobody
gonna come especially I mean code yeah
yeah they're all grilling outside
you know certain weeks that we don't
have the time ya know there's no reason
for me to work Father's Day Mother's Day
yester I got a family also if you don't
have a life you don't have comedy you
don't have come yes so yeah like you
could tell the [ __ ] they don't
have a life because the bits got no soul
is like I don't know like yeah I imagine
even having a daughter that changes your
comedy is like you got more soul your
soul expanded listen the first 10 years
of comedy I had nothing yeah and the
comedy reflects it right [ __ ] car
that nope yeah yeah no brakes
yeah what the love of comedy yeah
overrode everything so I simply does it
overrides everything yeah you know but
the comedy is self me the life man like
even like getting in a relationship
getting at a relationship like you could
tell when like a comic has just
experienced something because there's
something for them to [ __ ] chew on
and then you can tell the guys who like
you know they just don't have anything
so they can write really clever jokes
but there's nothing behind it
there's no passion like I would rather
hear you rant about a horrible uber ride
then hear some guys clever uber joke and
he can have more punch lines in his joke
but I know you've felt that way about
the uber ride I know you really felt
these [ __ ] things about the guy in
the front seat passenger the [ __ ] that
is
[Laughter]
pepperoni yeah I told that [ __ ] let me
get a great you know whatever the [ __ ]
they're eating then they have a
conversation and that person still on
the [ __ ] phone hey conduct your
business yeah
I listen to every [ __ ] word you're
saying
see what I'm saying
how much more enjoyable as it's like
that's just me maybe that's the type of
comedy that I tend to be a fan of but
like when I know somebody's passionate
about it it's real that's better than
any like little clever joke and I think
that's the people who tend to like have
like cult-like fan bases
it's the [ __ ] where like you
actually feel them you actually like
when they talk about something you know
they mean it that's their POV and it's
like okay I can latch on to this guy and
and that doesn't have to be always an
angry person
Theo's got it deels got it there's
something about Theo that you latch on
to him he's vulnerable right and then
there's there's guys who are passionate
like [ __ ] Kinnison had it it's just a
thing that when it's authentic in there
people gravitate and when it's not you
know you better have you better have a
billion dollar network behind you dog
you better have a because you won't need
it because the people laying on vacuum
it's like running for president man I
was telling somebody that day at the
time I've been here I could count eight
comics who they've tried very hard to
make a star how doesn't work they've
stood behind them with every opportunity
I could sit here and tell you seven
names I don't want to embarrass no body
and they're still around and they're
successful they're not Dave Chappelle
successful but nobody pushed Dave
Chappelle about our throats you can't
make a bow I fell in love with Dave
Chappelle to the Chappelle show and
before the Chappelle show for a lot of
people don't know it he was still around
20 years before that busting his hump he
got the crowd his developmental yeah I
still remember working with him in 97 I
still remember seeing him at the Boston
Comedy Club 94 with Robin Hood and Men
in Tights yeah great yeah that's how so
if I started 91-93 Chappelle was already
huge like he was with Jay Mohr that
night Nick DiPaolo and I was like an
open mic the probably [ __ ] young
proudest you know he um he studied
Barnet
no Charlie Barnet was a lame guy at the
[ __ ] park and you know so I don't
want people to think that Greer Barnes
Tony woods you could see what would some
guys on Chappelle man like and he was
such a student of the game that he he
was able to like you know pick up these
amazing you know tools and resources
from some of the most brilliant comics I
mean like Grier and Tony are some of the
best comics have ever lived like I mean
watching Tony woods is an experience man
it really is like there are a few people
that can you know when you see that
we've totally live everywhere
this [ __ ] could be performing in
like the living room of some prince in
Saudi Arabia he could be in India he
could be in the Bahamas anywhere he's
everywhere in nowhere at the same
[ __ ] time it is he's batman dude Tony
woods his mother [ __ ] Batman and we
don't know where he is but he's gonna
pop up and he'll deliver said when you
watch when you watch Appel in the last
special or even the bird revelation like
tell these long beautiful stories and
create such a calm and ease where you're
just like alright I'll listen even if
I'm not laughing I'm listening
I'm curious like for me that's the
school of Tony like Tony is I can listen
to Tony talk for two hours straight just
tell stories for two hours straight
comfortably I'm a comic eventually I'm
like I'm out of here it is the most fun
that you'll just it just calm there's
certain guys that are gonna like pound
you to death with punchlines you know
but and he's the type of guy that just
creates this amazing calm and then
rewards to calm with laughs and the [ __ ]
in it's great and I love those guys that
say well you need to read punchlines
every six minutes so no just be funny
you're not a scientist so Andrew it's a
real pleasure to get you in here Thank
You Man what you're doing is world class
I hope that a lot of comics are watching
you and cheering for you also too many
times you repeat you're one of the heirs
of Lenny Bruce okay
I consider myself one of the heirs of
money Bruce we're very lucky we all this
[ __ ] you were talking about
I would love to do a special see a
chandelier fall and the guide do 10
minutes on the chandelier falling you
know that's what I live for
yeah but the network's you know oh it's
gotta be polished contrived you know
I've seen people nitpick specials over
the years and it's for no reason the
bottom line it is it funny or not it's a
real man well the lighting wasn't gives
a [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] prove that all wrong
you forgiving all those [ __ ]
that said well you need to spend 250,000
and get a crane and ten midgets to dance
and a long opening I even loved your
opening you took it to some black guy
yeah he's selling your nickel bag you
get up and you go do your thing he went
right out there attack the [ __ ]
serene yeah payback
this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] that's why
he's doing what he's doing and the
audience he has is reading this
yeah but he's going against whatever
kind of essential things whenever
Netflix things would have HBO thought
economy whatever truTV things I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're thinking yeah
like a vice land shoot yourselves yeah
like eight networks to just there's like
eight networks that you would say you
think about yeah you really think about
how many networks in your heart you
would really want to go on it's tough
man in your heart you would go I really
want to go over there but if you're
gonna put me after who the [ __ ] wants to
go on Comedy Central there's nothing
there it's not there and they go deeper
and deeper into the hole or whatever you
show like really that's your answer
oh hey guys doing tremendous podcast and
this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] you pitched
for last
it's [ __ ] mind-boggling it's
mind-boggling [ __ ] crab feast is
doing better than most your [ __ ] joke
what's his name right that's a Ryan man
Nick was a [ __ ] savage yeah put him
on a [ __ ] show at 11 o'clock then
let's have three [ __ ] normal guests
but the people that they keep putting on
and shoving down your [ __ ]
throat and you're supposed to like him
one day you like I mean what do I like
this [ __ ] person for they're doing
everything for me to like him I like
people to do things for me not to like
like you you're not support because I
don't care if you like me or not he's on
his own universe what can people find
your brother my youtube youtube.com
slash Stand Rochelle's you check the
specials out there we put up stand up
every single week and a few different
shows we got this Travel Show and
they're dropping in or I do stand-up in
each city that we go on tour in and
another show called inside jokes is
pretty cool we're like we a few comics
come together we all bring a joke of
ours it's like too divisive piss off the
crowd and then we all kinda like work it
out and then you see us try it on stage
later so I'm just trying to treat it
like you know the comedy that I want to
see in the world I'm just trying to put
on my comedy channel and your website
yeah yeah be and Rachelle's calm and you
could get all like tickets for shows and
that kind of stuff there and I got a
couple podcasts Brillion 83 charlemagne
of god and flagrant 2 with our crush
thing and real life cast and shouts -
Alex media and Mark Gagnon my guys who
are doing all this great work so you
know man
you're doing God's work people though
thank you man that they could do it go
out there I started his podcast I
started this podcast not though we all
put our pants on one leg at a time but I
really started this podcast to let you
know that the rules were meant to be
broke as no rules facts just because I
was a felon I was supposed to give up
uh-huh I was supposed to give up for
half a disability get it check and tell
people the rest of my life I can't get a
job yeah as I'm a felon there's a felony
nobody would hire you if you go into it
looking at like that I say you're fine
that's what you'll find yeah we got no
rules [ __ ] the only rules look with
your [ __ ] rules
do not forget I'm at the Majestic Peter
13th and dollars a few tickets are left
San Antonio is gone I'm also doing a
workshop at the Comedy Store the 18th or
the 17th of the belly room I'm gonna
start doing a one-man show once a month
or the third Wednesday in a month check
Comedy Store dot-com for details and
September 27th at the [ __ ]
Chicago did it real
I want to give a shout out to the
sponsors the church what's happening I
was brought to you by my bookie football
season is here Thursday you [ __ ]
you like winning money or you want to
sit on your couch broke looking for
quarters in between you like betting
sports well I'll tell you where you can
put your money down my bookie calm if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
MMA whatever my bookies got don't forget
you got [ __ ] khabib against Poirier
this weekend now my booking they got
better incentives and more lines than
any other sports book period this year
they're running a super contest you
ready grab a pen it allows to enter you
pick five teams a week against the
spread and you rack up the points first
place is guaranteed $100,000 enough with
your [ __ ] that you went seven out of
seven last week enough put your money
where your [ __ ] mouth is they just
revamped their site and it's looking
[ __ ] tremendous so I'm gonna take a
look if you haven't already now do me a
favor we're gonna do over my bookie
we're gonna double your first deposit
today right now use promo code shirts to
get a hundred percent bonus and your
initial deposit of up to a thousand
dollars who's better than you nobody
[ __ ] visit my bookie dot AG today
that's my bookie grab a pen my B oh okay
ie dot AG and don't forget to use the
promo code Church CH you are CH when
creating your account to claim your
bonus you play you win you get paid and
don't forget to check my Instagram on
Thursday I'll be dropping a little video
with pics and [ __ ] around and making
bets you'll be saying uncle Joey's my
bookie from now on follow me I might add
Matt flame as well also the church is
brought to you by one of my favorites
it's keeping listen between Cuban coffee
Aleve and CBD Lyon that's what's keeping
me together that's the glue right yeah
dad whacked off I smoked my hands and
smell like CBD fluid that's how much CBD
is it my boy
but if it's in my body it's because of
CBD live.com oh yeah I coming here now
with the CBD dick you're done you're
gonna have [ __ ] eyes that's how
strong my sperm is picking a reliable
CBB company is like pulling [ __ ] and eat
no more but your uncle Joey got you with
CBD Lyon
they make their CBD products from start
to finish
CBD Lyon has you covered now listen if
you want to smoke shadow if you want to
do the vape if you want to the
cartridges they got you uncle Joey
I go with the gummi bears but my
favorite is the tension I put 5,000
milligrams under my tongue and I sleep
like a [ __ ] baby I don't have to get
up to pee their products are clean Bobby
and then I like the [ __ ] face it you
see it the jewelry at the [ __ ]
jewelry stores the 7-eleven a [ __ ]
some fungi from Isis trying to sell you
see me leave [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here you got Uncle Joe and I'm telling
you right now go to CBD line calm and
check out their third party lab results
yourself they're not [ __ ] around so
what I want you to do is this but a CBD
line see some tensions from chad is some
gummies pressing Church on the checkout
I'm gonna give you 20% off 20% off and
you're gonna live you're gonna be
healthy CBD oil is [ __ ] tremendous and
when it comes to it
CBD Lyon does the best again CBD Lyon
calm and my bookie dot AG I want to
thank Andrew Schultz I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] for
always having our back we'll see you
[ __ ] Monday morning ready to go
tip-top Magoo take this [ __ ] mealy